[Music]
foreign
I want to celebrate CUNY law as one of
the few if not the only law school to
make a public statement defending the
right of its students to organize and
speak out against Israeli settler
colonialism that as Israel continues to
indiscriminately rain bullets and bombs
on worshipers murdering the old the
young attacking even funerals and
graveyards as it encourages lynch mobs
to Target Palestinian homes and
businesses as it imprisons its children
as it continues its project of settler
colonialism expelling Palestinians from
their homes
carrying the ongoing nutba that our
silence is no longer acceptable
[Music]
foreign